stranger things season 2 has finally
been uploaded to Netflix I was a big fan
of the first season and I liked it quite
a bit so I was pretty excited to see
where they went
the duffer brothers created this show
and wrote and directed many of the
episodes just in case you have not yet
seen season 2 this review is gonna
contain some spoilers in this season
young will buyers has returned safely
but there's still some sort of
connection he's feeling with the
upside-down and the entities that reside
in it
his mother Joyce played by Winona Ryder
is very happy to have him back and
hopper played by David Harbor is keeping
the existence of young eleven hidden
from everyone else as he keeps her safe
in a cabin in the middle of the woods
treating her to Eggos every single
morning and while all of this is
happening the upside-down and the
creatures that reside in it are
threatening to take over Hawkins Indiana
I really enjoyed season two I think that
it's a good follow up to the first it's
a slow build season it takes a while to
set up events that lead you to the last
two episodes which I think are maybe the
best in the whole show the last two are
nail-biting the tension was so
high-strung it's pretty much what I
wanted out of stranger things it builds
to that fairly well and I feel like it
wouldn't have worked as well as it did
if the show hadn't have built slowly all
that being said for the first half of
the season I was curious where exactly
it was going it took a while to get my
interest back this season introduces new
characters one of them being a young
girl named Maxine who beat everyone's
score at Dig Dug at the arcade and this
character was probably one of my least
favorite additions to this season her
character felt like a wrench that was
thrown in the clockwork of the four main
boys which is necessary because they're
nearing puberty and that's gonna become
a very real thing for them and that's
one of the things that bothered me about
her character it felt like she was there
specifically to do that like her only
real purpose was to cause some problems
for these boys her character has a
backstory but it didn't really feel like
it brought much to the table beyond your
typical angsty young girl who has a hard
family life and there wasn't much else
beyond that it was clear that she was
there to cause drama between eleven and
Mike and there
reunion because you know they like each
other and then eventually she causes
drama between Mike and the other boys
because she's trying to get into their
club and Mike's not too happy about that
so it just felt a little more drama
heavy than I was expecting and I like
drama like real drama like Joyce being
afraid of what's going to happen to her
son when he becomes taken over by some
kind of entity that was really cool and
it led to some really hard decisions for
her character having to do some awful
things to her boy to get this thing out
of him which I thought was really
riveting but it was the middle school
romance drama that I felt was just a
little heavy-handed in this season if
we're talking about negatives let's just
get this out of the way episode 7 the
lost sister is I feel the first terrible
episode in this show it feels almost
like what's called a backdoor pilot a
pilot episode for a spin-off show snuck
into an already successful show this
entire episode did not work for me nor
did any of the performances in it's a
famiglia V Brown who is always excellent
as 11 and remains one of the best
characters of this show 8 another girl
who was at that same lab tested on I
found this entire episode to be a
strange detour that was very poorly
written and unnecessary 11 or Jane's
backstory is very relevant and very
pertinent to the show but the
exploration of it here felt so lazy to
me it felt almost like they took what
was the best character in the show and
tried to explore her background but not
doing that really exploring it in a way
that sets up a possible other story
which just seemed very very flaky to me
I would have loved an episode dedicated
to 11 and what she has dealt with but
it's more about who else dealt with it
and how we can set up those characters
too you could honestly skip that episode
and the only thing you would miss is
some character background stuff 411 and
why she changes her appearance beyond
that the episode was so out of left
field and very disappointing all that
out of the way I really like season 2 of
stranger things it built a lot of
dispense it set up relevant character
drama it did a really great thing at
shifting character relationships hopper
and Joyce spending more time with each
other
Sean Astin as Bob was a really good
addition to this season the boyfriend of
Joyce and seeing them in their
relationship was really sweet I also
love what they did with Steve Harrington
he became the best babysitter ever in
this season had a great relationship
with Dustin one of my favorite scenes in
the whole season was them walking on
these train tracks and Dustin trying to
describe how he felt about this girl he
likes
and Steve giving him that advice of well
this is what you have to do and then he
eventually reveals what he does with his
hair and it's little moments like that
that actually makes stranger things so
good it's not just the 80s nostalgia or
the creatures or the telekinesis it's
it's really just these small moments
between characters like hopper and Joyce
sharing a cigarette outside of the
school dance or Dustin doing his hair
the way Steve instructed him to it's
these small moments that make the show
special to me and these moments built
and built to create a very entertaining
season and once you see the way the show
culminates save for episode 7 you
understand why it took a while to build
some of these things and I think it was
a smart move I also like the direction
they took Nancy and Jonathan their
awkwardness and eventual realization of
how they feel
it took characters and shifted them in
ways where they were presented as
possibilities in season 1 but they're
going in different directions and I
really appreciated that particularly
with Steve Arrington he set up as such a
douche in the first season I would not
have expected him to be one of my
favorite characters this time around
also the CGI has greatly improved from
season 1 and the music is terrific
especially in the second to last episode
episode 8 very riveting stuff season 2
is really good I would say it's a hair
below season one and my main reason for
that beyond some of the character issues
I had and obviously that one terrible
episode is that it didn't quite have the
sense of urgency that the first season
had with will being missing this time
around will is still being used by the
creek
the upside down but the sense of urgency
was not as great but still it's a very
entertaining show with great characters
really good writing excellent
cinematography and it's also not quite
as derivative as the first season my
main issue with season 1 was that it
felt too much like a billion other
things I had seen before this one has a
lot of comparisons to aliens Paul
Reiser's in it there's creatures
underground and there are some alien
comparisons for sure but it didn't feel
as derivative this time around it felt
more original and I really enjoyed
season 2 and I'm looking forward to a
season 3 I'm gonna give season 2 a B+
guys thank you so much as I watch for
watching look forward to more videos
very soon and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuff my nice
[Music]